[Music]
so welcome to session 23 of the worlds
of speculative fiction series as our
third year here at the Brookfield Public
Library
we missed two sessions due to illness at
various times and that's why we're at 23
rather than 25 but I managed to get one
of them done and Bohr Hayes who were
doing today got put off from December he
got bumped from December to January
today we're looking at Jorge leave
Jorge's who one of my favorite authors
hands down like across fiction genres
not just in terms of speculative fiction
somebody who I've been reading and
rereading since I was a college student
will describe why cuz I have not read
them and I'm sure I'm here partly
because I want to decide if he's worth
reading yeah absolutely yeah I mean this
is this is the book that I had this is
the second copy of it because the first
one got got so worn out from my paging
through it and all that so yeah I'll
give you plenty of background and stuff
like that I'm sure we'll have a lot of
great discussion about him so as usual I
want to talk a bit about the narrative
world that he creates and this is kind
of complicated to talk about because
there isn't a coherent it's not like a
series you know some of the authors that
we have suddenly got to kind of piece it
together
and then we'll talk about his biography
he lived quite a long time and there is
five main or five or six main
philosophical themes that I wanted to
hit on and we can talk about others as
well
so one of them is chance determination
and free choice another one that's
really key and his thought is identity
and self you know who is who is a person
what do they know about themselves
another one that I thought would be kind
of interesting to explore is
misunderstandings in human inquiry and
the productive things that this this
generates
[Music]
and then language the world and
interpretation I think that's absolutely
central for more haze work I wanted an
attack also about infinity and different
different notions of infinity that are
in his work and then I think that kind
of dumped tales with his views on space
and time is rather metaphysical right
but but I he manages to bring it home in
very human ways so Before we jump into
it I you know I did mention I started
reading for Hayes as a college student
and I think I probably encountered it
the way a lot of other people did which
was in a comparative literature class
he's he's not usually taught in
philosophy classes as a matter of fact
when I tried to bring him into my my
philosophy classes as a graduate student
I got a lot of resistance from my
professors not all that into that idea
but you know one of them let me actually
write a short paper on board a sin
anesthetics class I found you know I
read the story of the Garden of forking
paths and then that got me interested in
that I bought the copy of this which is
you know pretty good it's got a
selection of some of his most important
stories I think it's probably the
easiest one to get hold of this is a
nice volume to collected fictions it's
got a lot of that stuff spanning his his
career and you know what I really liked
about Jorge's was when he is telling a
story and they're very short stories for
the most part I think the longest one is
under fifty pages there's always a lot
of philosophical ideas woven into it
sometimes quite deliberately and he
plays around with them sometimes they
almost assume central space in in in
what the story is about sometimes
they're kind of tangential and he's
telling a good detective story or
something along those lines and and I
think there's a lot he was incredibly
influential
a lot of other writers who were
interested in especially more in the
present he caught on you know by the
late sixties so he managed to influence
people who are closer to us in time than
say you know classic sci-fi authors
right or fantasy authors but he's had a
major impact he also had a major impact
in in you know his native language in
Spanish some people think of him as
being sort of the father of magical
realism as a genre which which fits into
speculative fiction and so you know they
look at other people in that genre as
having been influenced by him
I really can't say that much about it
because I don't read too much magical
realism stuff but you have so you know
you guys can fill in we're missing
things so let's talk about his his life
he's Argentinean but he's you know an
action where he reflects on this in a
couple essays to be Argentinian was not
like being from other parts of South
America in his view because because
there was so much back and forth are the
you know the origin times were looking
to Europe and he and his family actually
ended up spending a good bit of time in
Europe and you know Argentinian like
like many other countries is a country
of immigrants so there's people coming
in and coming out he's born in in a
suburb of wano saris and his father is
essentially a lawyer you know he does a
couple other things who breaks a novel
at one point and his father's an aside
and his mother say there's a lot of
mixed ancestry
and there's you know he talks about
learning English as a child within the
household so that they you know he
learned to read English before he
learned to read Spanish interestingly
enough although you know they would
they'd also speak Spanish
but it would you know we know Sirius is
a very cosmopolitan city I mean we might
think of it as sort of the the Buenos
Aires that he describes I think it's
sort of like the Chicago of my you know
parents generation where it was a lot of
little neighborhoods some of which were
associated with particular ethnicities a
lot of movement back in and out I know
some people might say it's more like New
York or something cuz they they they
like that but anyway he's born there and
he's educated at home he doesn't go to
school for a long time and and he's kind
of left to his own devices and in many
respects he writes his first short story
when he's when he's a seven and he
translates Oscar Wilde's the Happy
Prince into Spanish he's published in
the local newspaper and everyone thinks
that his dad actually did the
translation but it was actually it was
actually little Jorge and so the you
know he's got kind of nice childhood
going on there somebody asked about his
childhood and he said just paraphrasing
because I don't remember the exact
quotation one of the most important
events in his childhood was his family's
library so instead of talking about you
know like the time I fell down the
stairs at the time I realized this or
that he talks about the library itself
as being an event so he's a very bookish
kind of guy
his father ends up having some eye
problems and then he's going to become
afflicted with blindness later on in
life too so they moved to Switzerland
and his father undergoes some medical
treatment there and I mean this this is
a very nice environment to be and he
goes to this you know Colette edition
have learns to read and speak French
there he's sort of adding to his
repertoire starting to read more people
he receives his baccalaureate from there
and then his family moves to Spain and
you notice this is you know in between
the time of the
the first world war and then you know
the the wind down after that and he
joins as a young man there's this
ultra-smooth that among Spanish
literature and we'll talk about that in
just a moment he returns to Buenos Aires
in 1921 although he's going to go back
and forth between there and Europe quite
frequently and he starts to contribute
poems to a literary journal Martin
Fierro Martin fearo's is a hero of
Argentinean sort of national epic sort
of sort of like what the I guess you
could say sort of like what the Aeneid
is for you know old Romans or the
loosely dhatus is for Portuguese that's
that's sort of what Martin Fierro is the
way he describes it and he begins
spending time with his father's friend
Macedonia Fernandez and this guy was a
philosopher didn't write much down very
influential on a young bore haze as a
matter of fact a lot of the the key
themes that are gonna emerge is
important in his work later on Mossi
Macedonia Fernandez is dealing with he
he'd come up with very funny sayings
like he goes to a lecture and there's
very few people there and he says if
anybody else had failed to show up I
don't think we would have found the room
for them so he'd like to play with these
paradoxical sort of notions right sort
of like that poem about the guy who's
you know the the met Amanda wasn't there
yeah yeah and so there's paradise well
how can you be present an absence at the
same time these are philosophical
questions right
so very kind of like comedic sense that
while men language - yeah well I mean
you could say in shop or case is also
very into shot he he read a lot of
English authors he also really enjoyed
Stevenson
Chesterton so it you know you can you
can say kind of an interesting question
that question of influence you can say
Jorge's is influenced in the sense that
he draws inspiration or ideas from it
off there you can't say he's influenced
in the sense like he's following in the
path of a particular author right so
there's two different ways we can talk
about the influence I mean somebody who
read who again influential in a certain
sense but not in others was Arthur
Schopenhauer - who not only was an
interesting philosopher but also very
witty you know rather biting sardonic
you know now he gets involved in this
this this movement this ultra movement
and this is a literary movement that
begins in Spain and like a lot of things
in South America you know sort of washes
over into that context as well and their
idea was to oppose modernism ya know and
modernism in a literary sense not to
oppose the modern in general they
thought that the the moderns were in
some sense not modern enough so it's
it's got connections or similarities
with like Italian futurism that might be
a reference point
dadaism the Surrealists so in a sense
they're saying the modernists that's
great that they're pushing modernity but
they're not going far enough with that
so yeah I mean you might if we we use
our contemporary terms it might say
there since they were there post
modernist supposed you know as opposed
to modernist but post-modernism is
always a movement out of modernism and
they you know they stressed new
technology trying to bring together
graphic treatments and you know words so
some of their journals would actually be
like broad sheets that they would staple
to like a wall or something I'd have
people like read it there a lot of
experimental stuff and Bohr Hayes in
1922 he published a manifesto in
nosotros magazine and he summarized
their goals in this way reduction of the
lyric element to its primordial element
metaphor so metaphors are incredibly
important getting rid of middle
sentences linking participles and
adjectives so economy of language
avoiding ornamental artifacts preaching
far-fetched and nebulosity I mean that's
sort of a self referential thing because
that's kind of nebulous itself and then
synthesizing two or more images into one
widening it suggestiveness that's kind
of an interesting idea that's trying to
I would say actually like what do we
call those these days you know mashups
right so he's he's kind of talking about
bringing things together like that and
so that's that's where he is for a long
time and he writes poetry for the most
part I need rights you know manifestos
and think about he's in his 20s he's
caught up with this new movement and
that goes on for quite a while and and
you know eventually he's going to start
leaving that behind he pronounces the
death of Argentine halt Reyes well
that's already kind of dramatic thank
you when you're saying a movement is
dead you know it's probably not dead but
but you're making yourself really
central and eventually he starts writing
the stuff that we're you know we know
him for the almost dreamlike short
stories where he's meditating oftentimes
on philosophical themes the the real
impetus for that comes in the year that
his father dies
which is 1938 there's a very important
year for him his father dies and Bor hey
starts working at this library the the
Canaan municipal library there's there's
actually an interesting story about that
that I came across there was in a
working-class area and there weren't a
lot of books so cataloging you know was
a major thing for the librarians he was
told not to catalogue more than 100
books a day because if he did he was a
rate breaker
I know you're familiar with this term
from Labor Studies but you are too so a
rate breaker is somebody who exceeds the
rate of work that's been set within the
shop somehow so and it's usually done
informally right so everybody in the
library don't you know nobody should do
more than this about because you're
otherwise you're making us look bad and
so that's what they told them so he was
like what the hell am I supposed to do
all day and eventually he hid here I've
done an mo where he would spend the rest
of his day in the basement of the
library writing and translating stuff
and puttering around so seven-eighths
was his work day was you know maybe
maybe 4/5 of it or 2/3 of it was spent
doing stuff that wasn't in his job
description because they wouldn't let
him do his job
and he did that for a long time he only
loses that that position when Peron
comes to power
oh yeah I don't remember I think he fell
and hit his head
if I remember right and the big problem
is is he gets he gets blood poisoning in
the hospital and he almost dies he loses
his inability to speak for a short time
and I guess this is an experience that
really you know put things into
perspective for him and so he starts
experimenting with with this new style
of writing that we we now know him for
he at the same time his eyesight starts
to worry
so eventually it's gonna get to the
point where he actually becomes blind
and he will write about that he has a
few interesting love affairs most most
of which don't really go that well this
this Estrela canto he meets her he
actually proposes to her and she tells
them that you know I can't really marry
you because then we we have to be lovers
and we're not actually lovers because
you're a bad kisser you know she's
talked about it was being rather rather
clumsy and and ungraceful and it sends
if he didn't you know have have any sort
of relations but but I guess he wasn't
particularly a ladies man you could say
well yeah his marriages tend to be you
know other values sort of matters of
convenience the last marriage she's
going to become his literary executor
and she's a secretary for a long time
you know another thing that I suppose we
could jumping out of this this biography
a little bit you know the year-to-year
stuff as he loses his eyesight he is
placed into a very difficult position
not just in terms of being a librarian
but in terms of being a writer because
how do you write if you're if you lost
your eyesight so his mother actually
helps him out for for a long time he has
his secretaries who do some of that work
somebody else who I actually worked on
for a long time and wrote my
dissertation on loose Bloedel it would
be a really in some respects well you
wouldn't be a contemporary because he's
much older but he went through a similar
issue where he lost his eyesight and he
had he couldn't really effectively work
until he found a secretary who would
read things to him verbatim and then
once he did that he managed to compose
volume after volume after volume of work
so when you have the right person
working with you I guess
and you have enough you know mental
facility I don't think I could do it you
can really do a lot and so more haze you
know some of the other things that
happen so Peron is going to come to
power in Argentina and Boreas was
opposed to piranha
so you know not long after the the
peronist government takes over he loses
his job in the library and he you know
he he winds up going on a lecture
circuit some of his friends help him out
by this time he's already starting to
get a little bit of recognition outside
of the spanish-speaking area because
notice like the garden of forking paths'
appears in Ellery Queen which was a
really important pulp magazine at the
time once Peron gets out of power
Jorge's is back in you know the
limelight you could say he's appointed
to the directorship of the National
Library he's made a professor if I
remember right I think it's English and
Spanish literature at the University of
Buenos Aires and now he starts to like
become well-known internationally in
part because he's receiving prizes which
which bring him to people's attention
his work start to be much more
translated he starts to work with Norman
Thomas de Giovanni he's nominated for
but does not receive a Nobel Prize in
Literature that's I forget who got a
thing here but he Graham Greene and this
other guy were the finalists and the
other guy who I don't remember which
shows maybe he's not quite as good as
Graham Greene Herbert case he gets the
prize instead and and you know you
notice that he's got a lot of works here
and they're being published and I didn't
put all of his works in there mostly the
ones that have been translated
and I put the year the the Spanish
version of it not the year that the
English translation came out but he's
got quite a few collections of stories
he writes essays he write he continues
to write poetry and he's a guy the last
thing I said it's not in this biography
somebody who's continually learning even
after he's going blind he started
learning anglo-saxon yeah because he
wanted to understand something of not
only his you know English ancestry which
he had some of that but also to you know
be able to hear what Beowulf sounded
like you know and be able to understand
it and he continues producing through
throughout his life he travels a lot he
actually has you know like a couple
lectureships here and there University
of Texas at Austin is one place that
brings him in that by the way is a place
of that's kind of well-known in in the
semiotic area for like producing you
know books book series that are
important and then I think mores kind of
figures into that so there were people
who were into his his kind of stuff at
the time and he he dies of liver cancer
in 1986 having lived you know quite a
long life more than the 70 years made
some solid contributions got to see
unlike many of the figures that would be
for the death got to see people really
getting into his work Laden could see
him because he was blind got to got to
hear people he didn't get into his work
you know so I credibly the credit good
life overall and a lot of literature
produced as a result of it you know his
early stuff also this is the last thing
I'll say about his early stuff he he
didn't disavow it entirely but he said
that he was taking the wrong direction
and that it wasn't you know it wasn't
very good
he also worried that that some of the
earlier stuff and I think you can say
this about Italian futurism too would
get adapted by conservatives
or fascists as something that could
justify their their points of view and I
should say this about his politics so
what is blessing or who's described
himself as a classical liberal in the
meaning that he's somebody who he's not
you know the free-market liberal who
thinks that everything should be turned
into market-based solutions instead he
thinks that that individual liberty is
very important the state should be weak
and we should try to make individuals
strong so he was opposed equally to
fascism and nazism on the one side as he
was to communism he took a lot of heat
and lost a lot of friendships over
opposition to communism
he was also opposed to the Peron
government because the Peron government
it's difficult to say exactly how it
should be classified some people in
fascist Studies think that he we could
call it a fascist government others you
know stress the you know other sides to
it but he thought that it was yes that
way but it wasn't just a dictatorship
this is this is kind of a good point so
it in a regular military dictatorship it
says it's sort of hierarchical relation
right and you don't modify the whole
society Peron was similar to fascism and
communism in that he wanted to mobilize
the masses and to transform Argentinian
society from within so you definitely
was a populist right and he did he did
exercise dictatorial powers more Hayes
also you know he was first he was four
and then he was against the military
junta in Argentina so you know generally
he's going to be taking a position
against any sort of powerful government
but that I mean that's about as far as
it went
he wasn't very politically committed but
I thought that
kind of an important point so let's talk
about the narrative world I chose as a
title for for this this lecture
libraries and labyrinths and I did that
because those are kind of focal points
for of Jorge's stories and there isn't a
narrative world in the sense of an
overarching you know universe we're all
the same similar characters you know
encounter each other have their arcs
grow there there's not one single you
might say set of rules or principles
underlying all of all of his stories but
we can't say that the figure the
labyrinth shows up over and over and
over again and I wanted to bring up a
few examples so in his very first work
the universal history of iniquity he
talks about the the Mississippi Delta as
being there as having labyrinths of clay
dead fish and swamp reeds already he's
using that that sense you know in
another story he's actually got a guy
writing a book called the God of the
labyrinth this guy Herbert Wayne the
house of mysterion which is about the
Minotaur that's one of the stories that
made it into here that is is about a
labyrinth of course and the house of the
Styrian is the labyrinth that's it's a
house with this tyrion says fourteen
doors and fourteen means infinite the
Garden of forking paths that we'll talk
about a little bit more that's a that's
one where there's a labyrinth but the
labyrinth is actually a book and the
labyrinth is a metaphor for a greater
labyrinth which is time itself which is
a whole set of forking paths
in the labyrinth in the house no
beautiful it's so thick
oh I wouldn't doubt it I was with it in
directions you know so let's go into a
little digression here and I'll tell you
something a bit confessional so when I
when I read this as an undergraduate I
wanted to write a book and I actually
did start writing a book never finished
it and I'm sure whatever whatever files
I created their long sense lost on one
drive or another and it was going to be
called 14 infinite coming from the house
of mysterion's story and a part of it
was be you know because I thought in a
way that was so central to what Borghese
is doing here that that the whole thing
could be understood as a labyrinth or at
the whole book all of his stories
together and 14 I could pick that number
talked about 14 stories and that was
that would substitute for talking about
all the stories 14 could be infinite and
in this it's a very short one the house
of mysterion and trying to try to find
it it's very sympathetic to the Minotaur
as a matter of fact the Minotaur ends up
getting killed at the end and it's
almost tragic in a way so I'll just read
a little bit from yeah it's like read
four heads and just sort of updated yeah
I wouldn't I wouldn't with time okay
well bourget's definitely sees time
itself as a labyrinth and and time can
be understood not just in terms of like
an individual's trajectory through time
or time as like you know the
metaphysical thing that we're all moving
in but but also history right so and
you'll appreciate this as a journalist
you know you think about a story that
gets told all right it can be looked at
from a number of different perspectives
and anything interesting is almost
always controversial right
so there isn't that coherent everyone
agrees that this is the story and
there's usually if you dig into it well
enough there's going to be some things
where the official story turns out not
to be not to be the truth right so all
of those are aspects of the time so he
you know in this the the Minotaur is
telling his story says I know they
accused me of arrogance
perhaps a misanthrope misanthrope II
perhaps of madness it's true I never
leave my house but it's also true that
it's doors whose number are infinite or
open day and night to men into animals
as well anyone may enter and he goes on
and he talks about you know how he
spends the day running through places he
imagines anotherís Tyrion I pretend he
comes to visit me and I show him my
house with great abhi ciients that say
to him now we shall return to the first
intersection or now we shall come out
into another courtyard where I knew you
would like to drain or now you will see
a pool that was filled with sand
sometimes they make a mistake and then
the two of us laugh heartily and then he
goes on and he says is where we get to
the like telling the story about the
what's happening in the labyrinth every
nine years nine men enter the house so
that I may deliver them from all evil I
hear their steps were their voices in
the depth of the stone galleries and I
run joyfully to find them the ceremony
lasts a few minutes they fall one after
another without my having to bloody my
hands they remain where they fell on
their bodies help distinguish one
gallery from another I don't know who
they are but I do know that one of them
prophesied at the moment of his death
someday my Redeemer would come so he's
associating the killing of other people
in the labyrinth with somehow freeing
them up it's almost like a like a Greek
mystery you know freeing them from this
life so then he says since then my
loneliness does not pain me because I
know my redeemer lives and he will
finally rise above the dust and then he
asked what will my redeemer be like will
he be a bull or a man will he be perhaps
a bull with a face of a man or will he
be like me and then the
under that is the Morning Sun
reverberating from the bronze sword
there was no longer even a vestige of
blood would you believe it Ariadne said
Theseus than the Minotaur scarcely
defended himself
why didn't he defend himself because it
you know he he was ready to be
slaughtered because for him in his frame
of reference that was being liberated
and you know we I mean it's sort of like
that that that story I forget who wrote
the book
some of you one of you will know it the
sort of revision of the story of Grendel
and Beowulf who was the guy who wrote
that where he tells his Grendel's
science story yeah and that's what Boris
I thinks is doing with with this you
know but but the labyrinth so what is
the labyrinth about it you know
sometimes it's constructed to keep
somebody in the one that Daedalus
created that you know the Minotaur is
supposed to be in this is supposed to
keep him from getting out to the rest of
the world and of course you know - puts
Daedalus and Icarus in there - you know
it's kind of kind of smart if you don't
want anyone to know how to get there
they're their way out but it might also
be to keep others out and that's the way
a lot of labyrinths are in Bohr his
stories the things that we have to
penetrate into if you think about it
means you know why why do you set up a
maze it's to protect in the area to keep
it to keep so sure like with
cybersecurity we we don't set up mazes
as such we set up all sorts of things
that make it difficult to figure out
where the real vulnerabilities lie and
so anything could become a maze right i
you know think about a story in politics
or even a better example than our own
time conspiracy theories right why why
some conspiracy theories so that nobody
will ever figure out the real conspiracy
right so that could be a labyrinth
and so that runs throughout olive bore
Hayes works this this notion of that the
other thing is library and I mean we're
in a library right now and libraries are
kind of changing their function these
days too which is an interesting thing
to talk about but they are still
associated primarily with books right
what makes something a library is it
just having books or does there have to
be there's there have to be more than
that and in order for it to be a library
I think there's something really
interesting about the trust hood
community that a library requires
because yeah you know for zero fees
essentially you provide some
documentation that you're part of that
community then you get a card and it
entitles you to maybe a limit books but
I think even here it's like you can have
a hundred books
the idea that I could go and take out
125 of these books and then perhaps
never returned you know that's a better
way of saying there's a trust in the
community that I'm going to take care of
it carefully bring it back and make sure
that I return it to its rightful place
yeah but I also get such incredible
value because I can do that as many
times as I want and if I were to even
even like at a half-price bookstore or a
bargain book then reaches a quarter even
the millions of dollars you could spend
over your lifetime the books that you
could just as easily get for free at the
library and the library has a commitment
to not only carrying I think it sends a
certain element of like like a canonical
some sort of canonical record right like
you expect them to have certain books
within sci-fi or fantasy or literature
fiction and or you know nonfiction but
they also continue to purchase and add
to their collection yeah and really
serve the commune
you know what about private libraries
that you know we have a private we have
a library at home given given all of our
books you know yeah
talks about his family library but also
his most famous library there's no way
you can check the book libraries Babel
you can never so let's talk about that
one so this is this is the library has a
universe and here I think they're going
to be useful to read a few guys from it
this I think has given rise to a lot of
ideas within you know sci-fi and fantasy
but what might be like this so he says
the universe which others call the
library is composed of an infinite
indefinite and perhaps infinite number
of hexagonal galleries with vast air
shafts between surrounded by very low
railings from any of the hexagons one
can see interminably the upper and lower
floors the distribution of the galleries
is invariable twenty shelves five long
shelves per side cover all the sides
except to their height scarcely exceeds
that at the notice we since a normal
book case there's a frame of reference
there's something outside of it one of
the three sides leads to a narrow
hallway which opens onto the gallery he
goes on and on each of these these
shelves there applause and unlike the
books in our library which mostly makes
sense in this library
they they they presume every single
possible combination of letters is
generated within these these books so he
says there are five shelves for you to
the hexagons walls each shelf contains
thirty five books of uniform format each
is four hundred and ten pages each page
of forty lines each line of some 80
letters which are black in color
there are also letters on the spine the
letters don't indicate or prefigure what
the pages will say and
each of the the books could just be one
letter repeated over and over and over
again or it could be Shakespeare or it
could be whatever and so in a way it's
kind of its kind of chaos right within a
very organized system and there's a lot
of theorization about you know whether
books could say refer to themselves or
you know whether each book is
irreplaceable I mean that he doesn't say
at one point that there were like
schisms and and Wars people killing each
other many books were destroyed but the
good thing is for any book that gets
destroyed there's gonna be one that's
just one letter off from it so you're
not gonna lose it all together and you
don't know which one was the the best
one anyway so that's that's one well so
that's a good question I mean it is one
coherent universe although - yeah so
this is this isn't a very important
partisan library
notion for poor Hays each book because
of it being a book could be describing
the entire world alright so on the one
hand we've got like the the book as sort
of the key for understanding the world
it's a very very old concept you know
this is a common idea in an ancient and
medieval thought on the other hand maybe
the entire world can be understood as a
book that's something that we read if we
if we know the right way to unpack it
you might say if we know how to figure
out what's being said so those are those
are key ideas and then yeah is it a
multiverse well I mean you could have
multiple books right and each of them
there's just a little bit off from the
other one
one book that contains the complete
justification of their life yes say that
are equally convincing but false yes
every possible iteration of a book
exists in the library
yeah so this justification idea for each
person there would be a book which would
describe everything you've ever did and
why why it's it's okay you know so it
would even justify you and wouldn't it
be nice to have something like that but
you're right
all it would take would be inserting a
not wrong there's actually a website
with the library of Babel online which
so one nano actually I wrote my first
page and then I searched for it in the
library of the Bell and it's really
eerie because you'll find the paragraph
you just wrote because it's you know it
is funny though because there's no way
in that particular story to make it work
without there being some sort of
external frame of reference it's
supposed to be it can totally contain
universe right please you can't you
can't pull it off and I think Boreas
knows that but when you're first reading
it through you're like yeah this this
this actually maybe I could be in this
thing maybe that could be a metaphor for
the world there's there's other worlds
or mind sets you could say with their
own worlds that he describes that are
very different from our own the library
of Babel being one of them but there's
another story called toin book bar or
mist here ts in which you could say
fiction intrudes into the
and I think we have a lot of examples of
something like this happening today you
know in various forms so in this this
story fund they they find an
encyclopedia and it's got an extra entry
in it and it turns out that there were
there were human beings in in the real
world who decided to like make up an
imaginary place and they would they
would work in different ways because
everybody there would be in effect a
Berkeley and idealist
so Berkeley Berkeley actually was
supposed to be pronounced was a British
philosopher who was in between Locke and
him and he argued that there really was
no such thing as a manner that
everything is just ideas in the mind or
as he put it the ideas for spirits God
being a spirit all of us being spirits
and we could never you know there is
nothing there's no substance out there
life this is not a substance this is
just a bunch of perceptions that we have
and they're consistent just like they're
showing up on you know on that camera as
a bunch of data right it's that closer
to Plato's well Plato thought that there
were real archetypes and then they were
copied in material substances and the
material substances aren't as good as
the archetype the archetype is you know
more beautiful or real but that's that's
something that's that's real in the mind
is you could say a third thing apart
from that so you got the material object
mind and then archetype you know various
other thinkers trying to put the
archetypes into the mind right Berkeley
is saying something a bit more radical
namely that well I'll just read you some
of the examples that that jorge's gives
you in this about what would it would be
like for for them so he says
there we go the classical culture of
flan compromises only one discipline
psychology all others are subordinated
to it the men of this planet conceive
the universe is a series of mental
processes which do not develop in space
but successfully in time they don't
conceive that the spatial exists in time
the perception of a cloud of smoke on
the horizon and then of the birding
field and they then of the
half-extinguished cigarette that
produced the blaze is considered merely
an example of the association of ideas
and he says that in the languages that
they have even the languages represent
this the world for them is not a
concourse of objects in space
it's a heterogeneous series of
independent acts there are no nouns in
Tuan's conjectural Irish rock of its
original language there are impersonal
verbs modified by monosyllabic suffixes
or prefixes with an adverbial value so
he says for example there is no word
corresponding to moon there is a verb
which in english would be to moon or to
moon 8 so you know it's a very different
frame of reference and now what does
boria's doing he's he's imagining a way
of life like this and it comes into our
world through through books through
encyclopedias and then it catches on and
then eventually like infects our world
and nobody can nobody can get good free
of it and eventually plon artifacts from
plants are showing up in the world and
now we're in real trouble because we're
gonna be you know living in that thing
eventually the library Babel another
another example he's got another one
called fused the memoria
another translation I think it's fused
his memory and it's been a guy who is
again mindset very different from ours
who sees each thing as an individual
thing and you know you might say why I
see individuals as individuals right
there's four people in the room but we
see largely through through something
like archetypes
you know the patterns that we share with
each other fewn sees each thing as a
separate thing and remembers things and
and tries to make sense out of the world
through this and and Bohr he says he
doesn't really have a world the way that
we do instead of seeing a shoe like as
an archetype Joe is recalling every shoe
she's seen as a titrate leg the way that
her mind was working yeah and she was
talking a little bit about that about
you know part of her struggle being an
opportunity to create connections and to
sort of like be able to catalog these
differently so that the individual thing
that's being seen has a different
context yeah yeah that's her greatest
gift is being able to see all of these
you know to look at for example a pen of
cattle being held and to see each
individual as a couple as a cow
experiencing something in that moment
that was like you know they're new in
many ways that's the gift of her autism
yeah is the way in which she's able to
not only reintegrate through careful
practice but also see all of those
individual things yeah no but it was
overwhelming I think it's part of what
the desensitization that she needed to
create for herself was meant to combat
is that overwhelm of walking into a room
and not seeing you know set up a little
bit yeah I mean every
almost do not have a concept of cow as
in category well she did but what you're
saying is it was a way of learning to
think differently because of her autism
effects at her hurt the way that her
brain initially saw things was her
collections were different than her much
closer to they like the individual
things but she was able to recognize
patterns instantaneously because you can
see how each individual thing fit into
part of the pattern yeah
so here's from a few as the memorials
says lock in the 17th century postulated
and it rejected an impossible language
in which each individual thing each
stone each bird each branch would have
its own name fuse once projected a
analogous language but discarded it
because it seemed to general to him too
ambiguous in fact fuse remembered not
only every leaf of every tree of every
wood but every one of the times he had
perceived or imagined it
he decided to reduce each of his past
days to some seventy thousand memories
which would be defined by some means of
ciphers he was dissuaded from this by
two considerations his awareness that
the task was interminable and his
awareness that it was useful useless he
thought that by the hour of his death he
would not even have finished classifying
all the memories of his childhood and if
you think about what you know what goes
on in our perception right we are way
way more at any moment then we can
possibly conceptualize and and you know
the reason we're all functional is
because we leave out almost 99% of what
we're we're perceiving this guy is doing
something different and Boreas places
himself as best as he can into that
frame of reference through the medium of
imaginative literature and then says
what would that be like and we were
getting quite quite far away from
library so let me mention one other
thing about the theme of libraries more
haze makes up books and this is one of
the things that I think a lot of people
have tried to imitate him in he actually
creates books that
exist he's not unique in that the HP
Lovecraft of course did that too of the
Necronomicon and other people do that
too
but it's difficult to pull off right
it's difficult to get people to think
that there's something in a book that
that you don't you don't have and that
he's citing from and sometimes footnoted
yeah exactly yeah yeah okay that's a
great example - yeah yeah I mean in a
sense it's Boreas is almost you can
think about journalism again someone's
doing the opposite of journalism right
he's making up his sources you're not
supposed to do that you're supposed to
actually get to the get to the heart of
the story Matt and that make up the
story as he go along describes their
structure yeah it was because he loves
doing structuring it I won't say a cheat
for him but a way to he doesn't have to
write the whole book to do the part that
truly interests him which is given a
different yeah it's a good trick yeah
you you or you you can also he not only
does that with like making up books he
also makes up books that are like making
an argument against that original book
you know I guess you know in a way to
Frank Herbert did that too with like the
orange Catholic Bible or some of the
other books that so it's not a unique
thing but it's an interesting device and
and he does have a one story die you
know pierre menard author of the quixote
right here he imagines this guy who's
not not real pure Bernard and he writes
a whole series of what the guy wrote
he's so like his catalog and then he
says that he rewrote the Quixote by
writing the the same Quixote but it has
very different meaning now you know when
you're writing it as a 20th century
Frenchman than it did when Quinn
Cervantes wrote it but in some some
respects it's a richer composition
see if I can find that yeah here we got
36 so so he's the he's got a whole list
of all the works that this guy wrote
this is completely fictional he's he's
actually introduced like some some other
controversies in there so one of this
guy's patrons is a lien woman yeah
the countess Magna Reggio he writes a
definition of her which is supposed to
rectify the inevitable inevitable
falsifications of journalism to present
to the world and to Italy an authentic
image of her person so often exposed by
the very reason of her beauty and her
activities to erroneous or hasty
interpretation and she turns out to be
somebody who has supported him it has
worked all completely fictional so you
know that's that's the so quite external
the good thing is they're all short so
they're very easy but no what are you
getting up so that's a good question
what I get is more haze leads me to sort
of like play around with ideas in ways
that I might not ordinarily do by using
the narrative form he gets me who's
somebody who you know thinks about
things sort of for a living to think
about them from a different angle I
would say to think about them you know
for example metaphysical things like
time or whether we're really free or not
or what you know what what it is what's
the difference between reality and
fiction so think about those now if
there's in a different way but I think I
guess you could say he provides things
to fix our attention
you know examples that we can use sort
of like what goes on in good
philosophical thought experiments you
know what do you you know you've read
this right but these are thought
experiments he gives you new they're a
lot more vivid though than the stuff
that a philosophical literature yeah
it's like you read an entire novel and a
year later you remember one or two
images and bore Hayes's made up entirely
of those one or two images who remembers
yeah so one of the themes that I'd
really wanted to hit on was was chance
determination and free choice and I
actually went through and made a handout
just on what is for me my favorite Jorge
story which is called both the lottery
and Babylon and there's a number of
different phases in this he starts out
and typical 40s kind of stuff nobody
really knows you know if these stories
are true and I'm you know there's been a
lottery in Babylon
I'm gonna tell you what what I've heard
and then he goes in and just as if he
hadn't said any of that tells the story
and then gets to the end and kind of
calls it into question so in the the
lottery in Babylon what starts out is
you've just got a lottery you know sort
of like the lottery that we have here
with the Powerball all right everybody
puts in some money and somebody's gonna
win and most people are going to lose
and it's you know the common people who
play it it's not very good for them to
do and the lottery company starts losing
money because people are like this this
doesn't really hold our attraction and
he says these so-called lotteries were a
failure they had no moral force forever
they appealed not to all a man's
faculties but only to one of them to
hope for this right which is think of
when people buy lottery tickets today
that's
what's going on so they introduced
something
one out of four for everyone forever for
every 30 good tickets there's one bad
ticket that gives you a find so imagine
if we change the lottery like the
Powerball and like you know the
Powerball is not a good example because
there's so few winners so think about
the scratch-off tickets yeah so and it's
very rare you know one out of one
compared to thirty thirty winners to one
loser but that loser has to pay a fine
now you would say from a rational
perspective that becomes a bad lottery
why plant you know but it actually gets
people playing it more and I think there
is something to this that it appeals to
to two emotions now hope and fear and
society starts to change people who
don't play the lottery start to be
called cowards why aren't you taking a
chance and then a new thing happens
because people start refusing to pay the
fines they also start to you know in in
that society start say well if you pay
the fun you're a sucker you know you're
a coward you shouldn't you shouldn't do
that so all these people get good you
know behind in the fines the companies
like what are we gonna do we're gonna
run out of money pretty soon and so they
take them to court and the judge decrees
that the loser should put either pay the
fine and court costs or go to jail so
the loser is decided to go to jail to
try to defraud the company it doesn't
work but it introduces another new
wrinkle into the game because now what
you're comparing is no longer money
against money right you're comparing
money against jail time money loss and
gain and so now the lottery extends the
time in the company after a while says
well what what will do is the losing
tickets just have to have a jail time
you know they go to prison for a certain
amount and this is such a successful
thing that they're forced by the
ordinary people to increase the number
of
lucky numbers don't you again seems
rather irrational doesn't it but we're
talking about the play of the passions
here so where he says this is the first
introduction of non-pecuniary elements
in the lottery then there's people
complaining as there always are there's
two complaints that come in one is from
the people he calls the more or less so
these are like the you know the essayist
and philosophers and they say look the
winning prizes are about money but you
can't really be guaranteed that money is
going to buy you happiness so maybe it
should be more direct like you know
maybe you should you know win a nice
meal or you know a beautiful spouse
comes to your room or whatever right and
then the the ordinary people are like
hey the rich they can buy a lot more
tickets than that than we can so this is
unfair the rich get to experience the
highs and lows of life more than we do
this needs to change which is the
Equality of participation so then
there's a crisis and it's a terrible
crisis but you know it's it's one that
introduces a paradigm so slave steals a
ticket and that ticket in the drawing
turns out to merit having his tongue
burn down which is also the penalty for
stealing a ticket so now the question
that there's no question he's gonna have
his tongue burned out the only question
is what is the justification for it if
he gets his tongue burned out because
it's the penalty then the lottery really
isn't being rigorously applied is it but
if they're generous with them and they
allow him to his tongue burned out
because that's what the ticket said then
he's evading punishment so you know
justice and injustice get mixed together
in a very strange way and the company
this provokes a big crisis and the
company takes over it takes over the
culture of Babylon
it says the company was forced to assume
all public power the lottery that was
made secret free of charge and open all
by being a Babylonian citizen of a
certain age you automatically
part of the lottery so it requires a
comprehensive coordination of everything
that's taking place within Babylon by
the company and it says sometimes a
single of that would be a inspired
outcome of 30 or 40 drawings because
remember the tickets now are about all
sorts of things that could happen to you
in life and it's not just about your
life and what happens to you because
what happens to you also might affect me
and what's going on with me might might
affect the next person over so the
company somehow in some very complicated
way is coordinating all these different
chance drawings and the company becomes
all-powerful some people start
complaining that that you know could be
favoritism or corruption and so the
company responds with an argument and it
happens in if I remember right a mask
Factory it's written on a little thing
because the company is never just
responds directly to the people the
company says the lottery is an
interpolation of chanson to the order of
the universe to accept errors as to
strengthen chance not not to contribute
it so if there is corruption if there is
favoritism if there are errors that just
introduces more chance and the company
is the one who is taking a otherwise
orderly universe an introducing chance
into it and so this starts a lot of
debates among among the citizens and
these lead to new reforms which are
going to raise the level of chance in
the drawings so where they end up is
that drawings lead to further drawings
which specify modify and perhaps even
nullify the first drawing and so where
he says in reality the number of
drawings is infinite no decision is
final
all branch into others the ignorance
assume that infinite drawings require
infinite time actually all that's needed
is that time be infinitely sub divisible
which means that these lottery people
the company was running it
they have superhuman powers if they're
actually doing this
there's also impersonal drive
now there's not just the coordination of
all these different drawings happening
there's also impersonal drawings so he
gives us examples like somebody
introduces a snake into a jar of wine or
every every so often it was a great
example in here where is that here we go
one proposes the sapphire of table top
rope on ax B throw it into the waters of
the Euphrates another that a bird be
released from the roof of a tower
another that each century there be
withdrawn or added a grain of sand from
the innumerable ones on the beach the
consequences are at times terrible and
so the grand effectiveness is that
everybody in Babylon feels like their
lives are just some fuse with randomness
with chance with possibility now here's
the interesting there's there's one
other interesting question that we'll
come back to but here's the interesting
question in terms of like freedom are
people living in a domain like that free
in the sense of having freedom of choice
or free will they're escaping
determinism but they've got all these
weird random things being thrown in
there which seem to affect what their
life is like and maybe even things that
they think are themselves making free
choices are some in some way guided by
this mysterious company so are they are
they free or not do they have some
measure of freedom of choice it seems
like they can you know act within the
scope of what they're given can they
can they refuse to be involved in the
lottery no I mean if you're in Babylon
you are stuck in the environment that so
that's not free okay
that's not free in that sense but I mean
I mean the ultimate choice is always
life or death right so you could kill
yourself
you possess yes so you can't leave them
and we can't take the choice of doubt
that's really not one what if that's
something that's just the outcome of a
bunch of different drawings that the
company has done you know that's right
yes and so he he ends it by saying the
company with divine modesty avoids all
publicity its agents as is natural or
secret and so he says who can brag about
being a mere imposter the drunkard
improvises an absurd order the dream of
a wake suddenly and strangles the woman
who sleeps that aside do they not
execute perhaps the secret decision of
the company that silent functioning
comparable to gods gives rise to all
sorts of conjectures so here's the
conjectures one of these insinuates the
company has not existed for centuries
and the sacred disorder of our lives is
pure purely hereditary and traditional
so that the company is just kind of part
of our mythology and it hasn't existed
for a long time sort of like you know we
talk about like that you know the free
market and the invisible hand that's all
pathology when we come down to it maybe
it's something that they used to guide
their lives he says another judges that
it is eternal and teaches it will last
until the last night when the last God
annihilates the world
another declares the company is an
impotent but it only has influence in
tiny things in a bird's call the
shadings of rust and of dust and the
half dreams of dawn here's the
interesting another is that it has never
existed and will not exist so could you
tell whether any of those
I mean imagine we were in a situation
like that would we be able to decide
between these different possibilities
[Music]
given the the prophecies it seems hard
to figure out how we would all right
because it's a yeah to get out of bad
luck yeah
well I think it's one of those things
too the word if you're from Babylon you
going off to a foreign place that would
also be you know the company somehow the
company is behind it you know or they or
they put in your head the idea that you
shouldn't put up with this sort of thing
or you know yeah once you start going
down that line of thinking it's sort of
like with conspiracy theories right
people who have conspiracy theories
typically get one and then they tweak it
you know and then if you say well look
the evidence shows that this is not the
case that's not the case oh they got to
you you know there's always ways to to
say that it can't be falsified which is
yeah I mean I think that's the way it
works some of the time there's there's
an experiential aspect I mean people
talk about things changing their life or
you know you've got a feud if you're if
you want to see whether whether
meditation works you can you meditate
and see whether it makes any difference
or sometimes yeah I think you're right
that there's there's always gonna be
some aspects that you're never going to
have
possible experiences that that everybody
would be convinced by for right so there
has to be some element of taking it on
faith you get in a certain sense you
could say conspiracy theories Lisbon
Chesterton actually says at one point in
orthodoxy are kind of like impoverished
religions in a way religions are richer
in terms of the story that's being told
although some conspiracy theories are
pretty elaborate aren't they well rich I
mean you know I mean if you think about
like any of the great world religions
you could spend the rest of your life
just studying the literature of them
because there's there's so much you know
so there's a rich story because it might
be a false story but it's still a rich
story you know we could say something
similar about like gaming worlds you
know like some some game worlds are kind
of small and impoverished and others are
so vast that the players don't even know
what they're supposed to do and then
there was there was a game recently that
was so vast and so dope that that
players quit playing and I can't
remember was I remember reading about
that somewhere because they're like we
don't know what the hell we're supposed
to be doing yeah that limits help us so
that's a good segue into another key
idea so you know the world being open to
language and thereby being open to
interpretation this is a key idea in
more haste that you know he's got one
which is actually called one translation
the god script and other
the God we're like the whole universe is
really a set of correspondences if you
could sort of crack the code you would
you would understand it all the lottery
in Babylon trying to figure out what the
company is actually doing is kind of
along that that line there's a number of
different ones where we're I think he's
he's got this this it's a world that's
like I said mysterious but also
meaningful and and the key it's a
cracking it is to find how to read it
correctly how to interpret it correctly
you know and you can you can totally get
it run too so he's got a great story
where two actually two stories where
there were this theme comes up one is
three versions of Judas and the other
one is deutsches Requiem deutsches wreck
when it was about this this Nazi who is
sort of justifying what what he and the
other Nazis are doing and he gets to the
end and he realizes because sort of the
proof of the pudding for the Nazis was
that they were gonna win you know they
beat everybody else then there their
doctrine must have been true and he
comes to the point where he he says that
the point of the the whole Nazi you know
German exercise was to create something
new and it's not true it's not new
Germany he says many things will have to
be destroyed in order to construct the
new order now we know that Germany was
one of those things we've given more
than our lives who sacrificed the
destiny of our beloved fatherland let
others curse and weep I rejoice in the
fact our destiny completes a circle and
is perfect and then I mean this is where
it's kind of prescient story he says and
an external epic is spreading over the
world we forged it we who are already
its victim what matters if England is
the hammer and we the anvil so long as
violence reigns and not servile
Christian today
Victorine and justice and happiness or
not for germany let them be for other
nations that heaven exists even though
our dwelling place is hell and so
there's there's a sense that that there
is a meaning to life that just turns out
that you happen to be on the wrong side
of history but though you think we're on
the right side of history and that
meaning is going to go on but but notice
the kind of meaning is everything should
be violence
everything should be you know the
struggle of the strong against the weak
there's other alternatives for you know
how one would read the world as well but
I think that's one of the things that
his characters are typically doing is
trying to figure out how do I make sense
out of the world how do i how do I read
it properly like a book and so studying
language which is something else that
many of his characters do they're
linguists or they're they're
theoreticians of language would be one
way to do that
being a literary author would be another
way to do it another key idea is
identity in the self you know what you
know what are we he has one one great
story called the circular ruins where
there's a magician I guess we could call
him and he wants to create a living
meeting he wants to create a person and
so he does you know he prays to this
this this this God in a temple and he
engages in this visualization process
that eventually brings a new being new
person into being who is the only the
only difference between him and other
people is that fire can't Harmon because
he fire was used to create him and or
the fire God was used to create him and
so fire won't harm him and so he tries
to make sure that this guy never like
actually winds up in situations where
he's doing should get burned but doesn't
get burned so that he doesn't realize
that there's something up because he
doesn't want this this creation of his
to think of himself as a creation he
wants them to think of him as a real
living human being and
he takes care of this person who he
thinks of as his son and then eventually
in his own place there's a fire and he
realizes his own status when he starts
you know the fire is closing in on him
and he doesn't get burned and now he
realizes that he himself is a simulacrum
in a way or a creation of somebody else
so the notion that somehow you know the
things that we take for granted is being
certainties like I mean if you think
about when we talk about being you know
making ourselves well you know we've
been watching some black mirrors to
where that plays a role or well yeah
yeah and I mean there'll be a real kick
in the pants wouldn't it to find out
that your bet but in a way it's in a way
it'd be also relief I think to
especially if you realize that you
yourself were able to create something
so detailed so conscious that it itself
could think that it's real yeah you know
I'll mention one last theme because
because we should probably end priests
and so I said I would talk about human
inquiry and misunderstandings so he's
got a couple stories where people are
getting things wrong in ways that are
very interesting and it's usually with
with intellectual life and
interpretation so he's got one couple of
theologians and it's about heresies and
trials and stuff like that and these
these two theologians that are writing
things back and forth and one is going
after the other one which was something
that didn't happen in in you know
in the West in Christianity is you'd
have these these people you consider
their works you see if you follow out
this line of reasoning that leads to
this end and that's heresy so they must
recant good example that would be Peter
Abelard burn one of his books and in the
end they wind up in heaven and realized
that they're actually much more closely
connected and that they were getting
things wrong another great one is about
the the Islamic philosophy of eros and
it is let's see it's called avro search
yeah
even even rushed as Arabic name and it's
this wonderful story about oven roast
who's trying he's a translator and
commentator at Aristotle as a matter of
fact he was one of the people through
whom the medievals got to know Aristotle
again and he's trying to figure out what
Aristotle means in talking about tragedy
and comedy and he doesn't again he's
lacking a frame of reference because
he's not seeing anything like this in
the culture that he's living in there's
no drama as such there's poetry which
peopled acclaim and there is
storytelling and then he's the he has a
traveler who he's added like a dinner
party with and this travelers or County
haven't seen something really funny out
in China because you know the Islamic
world stretches across the continent
this traveler saw playing tries to
describe it in such a way that the
audience will be able to make sense of
it and in the end they basically come to
the conclusion boy these these
foreigners really do crazy stuff you
know and Averroes isn't able to make the
connection even though he's got it
staring him right in the face about what
Aristotle might mean by a tragedy and
comedy and so in the end
he writes a few lines where is says
Aristotle gives the name of tragedy to
panegyrics that of comedy to satires and
Anathem odds admirable tragedies and
comedies about and abound in the pages
of the Quran and the moja lacas of the
sanctuary and so here's here's the end
of what what Bourdais says in the
foregoing story I tried to narrate the
process of a defeat I thought first of
that Archbishop of Canterbury who took
it upon himself to prove that there is a
God then in the alchemists who sought
the Philosopher's Stone then of the vain
try sectors of the angle and squares of
the circle later I reflected it would be
more poetic to tell the case of a man
who sets himself a goal which is not
forbidden to others but which is to him
I remember a Burroughs who closed her
than the warp of Islam could never know
the meaning of the terms tragedy and
comedy and so he goes on and I mean this
could be our case as well that within
the frame of reference that we inhabit
there's there's things that we should be
able to understand that we just can't we
can't formulate adequately we lack the
cultural reference or we lack the
vocabulary how would we know again how
would we figure that out yeah yeah I
mean there you get somebody who is
outside of their cultures frame of
reference right Rossum is very
successful within his culture precisely
because he and successful as somebody
who's adapting previous culture to these
taking Aristotle and commenting on them
so I guess the more successful you are
within your own culture maybe the less
adapt to our context problem most
insight yeah well let me ask you also
does it sort of bring this to a close
because you've got this extensive
background in journalism when it comes
to like sources like that to actually
get up what's going on in the story how
do you how do you figure out who who are
the who are the outliers who you would
talk to to get the fuller picture I
think for me when I was doing stories I
always had believed everybody yeah I
really had this desire
everybody was telling the truth and I
was always kind of astounded when I hear
about people who were just lying flat oh
yeah it's just very strange for me
because my contest so so I wasn't always
looking for outliers I was just looking
for you know anybody who knew any
information about something but then
when I started putting information
together and I saw things that
conflicted yeah
that was that would be the red flag and
then I would have to go and sometimes I
would write stories and then realize I'd
have to completely rewrite them because
I have got something wait something so
something that would individually that
that one thing would change how to look
at the other offense they saw completely
and then you are always under a time
limit so yeah that's that's a different
time I I kill somebody off I should kill
them off in my story then I made this
last-minute phone call and actually got
him on the line and get the thing change
to the story before it was too late yeah
I imagine now that there's there's even
more pressure to try to get stories out
as quickly as possible or they are and
they're there for just huge numbers of
errors constantly
yeah that's one thing with Boreas is he
really had the luxury to what he wrote
and the things that he wrote a very
short for the most part to labor over
them as
as he wanted you know there wasn't any
pressure to publish yeah you know that's
a very yeah all right well let's let's
draw this one to to a close some great
discussion and we've got a lot of cool
authors ahead
[Music]